其他人：对okay
Other: Yes, okay.
其他人：然后让大家share of the gold
Other: And then let everyone share the gold.
Jake:那那那那那充充充一点
Jake: Then, then, then, then, charge a bit more.
Jake:怎么充啊
Jake: How to charge it?
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Jake:怎么搞啊
Jake: How do we do it?
Katrina: 面包在这里
Katrina: The bread is here.
Jake:你有一个朋友
Jake: You have a friend.
Jake:你
Jake: You.
Katrina: 我怎么了
Katrina: What's up with me?
Jake:有一个朋友
Jake: You have a friend.
Katrina: 嗯我给你讲什么故事
Katrina: Hmm, what story should I tell you?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我说我朋友怎么了
Katrina: I mean, what's up with my friend?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:敌友亦有
Jake: Friends and foes alike.
Jake:你没有朋友我有
Jake: You don't have a friend, but I do.
Jake:有你有一个朋友啊
Jake: You have a friend, right?
Shure: 我也有一个
Shure: I also have a friend.
Jake:你就啊你有一个朋友
Jake: You, you have a friend.
Jake:好你们都有一个朋友
Jake: Okay, you all have a friend.
Jake:谢斌竹没有朋友
Jake: Xie Binzhu has no friends.
Shure: 太可怜了吧
Shure: That's so sad.
Katrina: 能别刺激人家了
Katrina: Can you stop teasing them?
Katrina: 没有牛奶了吗
Katrina: Is there no milk left?
Katrina: 这是点的早饭
Katrina: This is the breakfast we ordered.
Jake:对这早饭粥
Jake: Yes, this is breakfast porridge.
Katrina: 啊啊啊
Katrina: Ah, ah, ah.
Jake:对吃吧
Jake: Yes, eat it.
Katrina: 有早饭
Katrina: There is breakfast.
Jake:对包子对
Jake: Yes, buns, yes.
Katrina: 哦这有牛奶
Katrina: Oh, there's milk here.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:哎哈喽
Jake:OK OK你在哪啊
Jake: OK, OK, where are you?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 我是新加坡的电话哈
Katrina: It's a call from Singapore.
Jake:是新加坡的
Jake: It's from Singapore.
Jake:然后给我说中文了
Jake: And they spoke to me in Chinese.
Jake:哎你好啊
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:你继续吧然后呢
Jake: You go ahead, then...
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:啊对对对对对是您说
Jake: Ah, right, right, it's you talking.
Jake:啊好好
Jake: Ah, okay, okay.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:呃行但我现在在国内啊
Jake: Uh, alright, but I'm in the country right now.
Jake:我国内我我过来大概要半个月吧
Jake: I'm in the country, it'll take me about half a month to get there.
Jake:呃对对是
Jake: Uh, right, right.
Katrina: 这薯条扔了吗
Katrina: Did you throw away these fries?
Katrina: 薯条煎蛋
Katrina: Fries and eggs.
Katrina: 中国特色
Katrina: Chinese specialty.
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah.
Jake:听不懂听不懂
Jake: Can't understand, can't understand.
Jake:你说英文吧要不
Jake: Why don't you speak English?
Tasha: 你说英文吧
Tasha: Why don't you speak English?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina: 点的烤红薯
Katrina: Roasted sweet potatoes.
Tasha: 搞什么
Tasha: What's going on?
Jake:哈
Jake:我逗他玩呢
Jake: I'm just messing with him.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Jake:真的
Jake: Really.
Jake:新加坡移民局
Jake: Singapore Immigration.
Shure: 刚刚说英文他撂了
Shure: As soon as we spoke English, he hung up.
Jake:对他掉了
Jake: Yeah, he hung up.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Ah, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 业务能力不到了
Katrina: Not skilled enough.
Katrina: 不过关了
Katrina: Not up to standard.
Katrina: 油条哈喽哈喽
Katrina: Hello, hello, you tiao (fried dough).
Jake:他就会说个哈喽
Jake: He can only say hello.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你放心
Tasha: Don't worry.
Tasha: 今天晚上我一定会把它吃掉的
Tasha: I'll definitely eat it all tonight.
Katrina: 你我这怎么分啊
Katrina: How are we dividing this?
Katrina: 这个粥这么大拿碗
Katrina: This porridge is so big, get a bowl.
Shure: 你放心明天早上8点一定会叫你的
Shure: Don't worry, I'll definitely wake you up at 8 AM tomorrow.
Katrina: 好好好哈哈哈
Katrina: Okay, okay, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈昨日重现啊这是
Jake: Hahaha, it's like yesterday all over again.
Shure: 你在这重现他们的
Shure: Are you recreating their...
Katrina: 一定可以的
Katrina: It will definitely work.
Katrina: 我也定了闹钟啊
Katrina: I also set an alarm.
Jake:看看你的快递
Jake: Check your package.
Shure: 是定了闹钟然后呢
Shure: You set an alarm, and then what?
Tasha: 这是石头剪刀布
Tasha: This is rock-paper-scissors.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Katrina: 没醒啊
Katrina: Didn't wake up.
Katrina: 按了定了4个闹钟全按了
Katrina: I set four alarms and snoozed them all.
Tasha: 垃圾转移
Tasha: Garbage transfer.
Katrina: 看一下这
Katrina: Look at this.
Shure: 来客之前不得收拾收拾吗
Shure: Shouldn't we clean up before guests arrive?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 就给我们的顾客看
Shure: Just show it to our customers.
Tasha: 看这个
Katrina: 呵呵跟他们说想吃什么
Katrina: Tell them what they want to eat.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Tasha: 想吃怎么自己拿
Tasha: If you want to eat, get it yourself.
Jake:盛情招待
Jake: Hospitality at its finest.
其他人： 哈哈哈随便吃
Others: Hahaha, eat whatever you want.
Jake:哈哈随便吃
Jake: Hahaha, eat whatever you want.
Jake:随自己烤
Jake: Grill it yourself.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 体验一下
Katrina: Experience it yourself.
Jake:还剩两个包子
Jake: There are two buns left.
Alice:有早饭吗
Alice: Is there breakfast?
Katrina: 好久没吃油条了好吃
Katrina: Haven't had fried dough sticks in a long time, so good.
其他人： 你来吗
Others: Are you coming?
Katrina: 急得谢斌竹
Katrina: So anxious, Xie Bin Zhu.
Katrina: 现场摇人了
Katrina: Recruiting on the spot.
Shure: 然后还有桌上那瓶伏特加你帮我拿着
Shure: And also that bottle of vodka on the table, could you get it for me?
Tasha: 音响呢不是说拿音响来吗
Tasha: The speakers, weren't you bringing the speakers?
Shure: 音箱跟麦克一起
Shure: The speakers are with the mic.
Tasha: 小
Tasha: Small.
Shure: 哇有油条
Shure: Wow, fried dough sticks.
Shure: 还热乎呢
Shure: And still warm.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
其他人：看看看看以太坊掉下来没有
Others: Look, look, did Ethereum drop?
Shure: 好购入我们的Ego币了是吧
Shure: Okay, so we bought our Ego coins, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:准备发售了
Jake: Ready for sale.
Jake:我们少了很多充电宝
Jake: We're missing a lot of power banks.
Jake:不知道发生了什么
Jake: Not sure what's going on.
Tasha: 我还想说我少了很多皮筋呢
Tasha: I was going to say I'm missing a lot of hair ties too.
Tasha: 我带过来至少10根不下皮筋
Tasha: I brought at least 10 hair ties.
Jake:这充电宝咋还没送呢
Jake: Why haven't the power banks been delivered yet?
Tasha: 今天一今天只剩最后一根了
Tasha: Today, I'm down to my last one.
Alice:给了我一根
Alice: I took one.
Tasha: 我是想扎个双马尾都扎不了
Tasha: I can't even tie a double ponytail now.
其他人：我靠太叼了一觉醒来掉下来了
Others: Damn, it fell off while I was sleeping.
Jake:哦多少钱
Jake: Oh, how much?
Katrina: 这怎么玩
Katrina: How do you play this?
其他人：这是0.181的
Others: This is 0.181.
Jake:哦这么少
Jake: Oh, that's so little.
Katrina: 对但这东西
Katrina: Yeah, but this thing...
Jake:牛批
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:炒币呢
Jake: Trading coins?
其他人：炒币呢这个拿命玩
Others: Trading coins, this is risky.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Jake:波动这么大
Jake: The fluctuation is so big.
其他人：就还好昨天晚上蹲到一个点
Others: It's okay, I monitored a point last night.
其他人：蹲到0.18 然后及时出来了.
其他人：虽然还没冲上去用
Others: Although it hasn't surged up yet.
Katrina: 用什么网站还是什么软件嘛
Katrina: Do you use a website or an app for this?
其他人：跟他关系好
Others: It's good to have connections.
其他人：我也不知道
Others: I don't know either.
其他人：我这
Others: I'm just here.
Katrina: 我一直想知道挖币的原理是什么
Katrina: I've always wondered how mining works.
其他人：就是一直算
Others: It's just constant calculations.
其他人：拿计算机算法写
Others: Using computer algorithms.
其他人：然后你算到了前面多少位
Others: Then you calculate up to a certain number of places.
其他人：是他指定的保险
Others: It's the specified insurance.
其他人：你就OK了
Others: Then you're good to go.
Jake:你就碰上了
Jake: You just hit it.
Jake:然后这就是你的了
Jake: And then it's yours.
其他人：嗯然后他就给你一点点
Others: Yeah, then they give you a little bit.
Katrina: 啊那这些程序算那东西啊
Katrina: Oh, so that's how these programs calculate this stuff.
其他人：这不是算
Others: That's not counting
其他人：这是发行的币
Others: That's issued currency
Shure:  哎我是不是可以拿我租的服务器挖矿
Shure: Hey, can I use my rented server to mine?
Jake:哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, you can
Shure: 反正闲着也是闲着
Shure: Anyway, it's idle
Jake:他会ban掉你吗
Jake: Will they ban you?
Shure: 我不知道啊
Shure: I don't know
Jake:试试试试
Jake: Give it a try
Jake:反正你不用
Jake: You're not using it anyway
Shure: 他肯定在监控我
Shure: They're definitely monitoring me
Jake:他肯定在监控
Jake: They're definitely monitoring
Katrina: 那他这个币的价格怎么定啊
Katrina: So how do they set the price of this currency?
其他人：币的价格就是共存在你的
Others: The price is based on what's available
Katrina: 嗯就是看你挖到那别人有没有挖到
Katrina: Yeah, it depends on if you mine it and if others mine it
Katrina: 就同同个时间段扔
Katrina: Then you throw it in the same time period
其他人：这个币的价值在于你觉得这个币未来好不好
Others: The value of the currency lies in whether you think it has a good future
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
其他人：嗯你觉得大家都觉得这个比未来好
Others: If everyone thinks it has a good future
其他人：那他不就更实际吗
Others: Then it's more practical, right?
其他人：比如说我们ego币
Others: For example, our ego coin
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
其他人：一开始一分不值
Others: It was worthless at first
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
其他人：但大家在二手物品非常的屌哎
Others: But everyone thought it was amazing for second-hand goods
其他人：这ego币就很有价值
Others: So ego coin became valuable
其他人：可能一开始刚拍
Others: Maybe at first during the first round of bidding
其他人：拍第一轮是将10个ego币
Others: It was 10 ego coins
其他人：后来大家越来越少
Others: Then fewer and fewer people
其他人：突然有一个傻吊一个
Others: Suddenly someone used one coin
其他人：一个币就换下了一个大东西
Others: To exchange for something big
其他人：然后整体就升值
Others: Then the overall value increased
其他人：这叫什么
Others: What's that called?
Katrina: 然后就可以
Katrina: Then you can
Katrina: 然后就可以卖掉吗
Katrina: Then you can sell it, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:虽然不知道
Jake: Even though I don't know
Jake:但是听起来不是
Jake: But it doesn't sound like it
Alice:有人喝粥吗
Alice: Does anyone want porridge?
Katrina: 什么粥看看
Katrina: What kind of porridge, let's see
Alice:我想喝咸的
Alice: I want salty porridge
Jake:喝喝呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Hehe
Katrina: 这什么粥
Katrina: What kind of congee is this?
Jake:银耳汤
Jake: Tremella soup
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 这好吃
Katrina: This is tasty
Katrina: 皮蛋瘦肉粥
Katrina: Century egg and lean pork congee
Alice:嗯我想喝咸的
Alice: Hmm, I want something savory
Katrina: 我也想喝咸的
Katrina: I want something savory too
Alice:拿个碗倒一下
Alice: Get a bowl and pour some out
Jake:我靠
Jake: Wow
Jake:你看他是要在群里发的
Jake: Look, he wants to post it in the group
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Wow, wow
Jake:哈哈哈壮观哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, spectacular, hahaha
Katrina: 啊啊我还是拿个碗吧
Katrina: Ah, I'll just get a bowl
Katrina: 我感觉我也吃不来了
Katrina: I don't think I can eat it either
Katrina: 我们的碗呢
Katrina: Where are our bowls?
Alice:那个里面没了
Alice: There's none left in there
Katrina: 没了
Katrina: None left
Jake:刷卡
Jake: Swipe the card
其他人：okay in your
Others: Okay, in your...
Jake:手机号
Jake: Phone number
Katrina: 拿怎么勺子的
Katrina: How did you get the spoon?
Katrina: 舀的吗
Katrina: Did you scoop it?
Jake:overseas Chinese bank
Jake: Overseas Chinese Bank
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh
Shure:  有时候有他的这个全部信息
Shure: Sometimes he has all this information
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right
Jake:但是他没有眼睛
Jake: But he doesn't have eyes
Jake:你现在有是吗
Jake: Do you have them now?
Jake:你没插电
Jake: You didn't plug it in
Shure: 我还没开
Shure: I haven't turned it on yet
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:有勺子
Alice: There's a spoon
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:approved
Jake: Approved
Shure: 这个磁吸夹头发跟那个麦卡
Shure: This magnetic hair clip and that mic
Shure: 那边反馈
Shure: Feedback from over there
Jake:只是戴眼镜有真实感
Jake: Wearing glasses gives a sense of reality
其他人：哦卧槽
Others: Oh, damn
Jake:卧槽涨了
Jake: Whoa, it's gone up.
Jake:已经涨了啊
Jake: It's already up, huh?
其他人：涨了1.15
Others: It's up by 1.15.
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Oh my god, oh my god.
其他人：没见过这时候
Others: Never seen this time before.
Jake:刚买就暴跌
Jake: Just bought and it crashed.
Jake:我靠哈哈
Jake: Oh my god, haha.
Katrina: 呵呵呵没没没
Katrina: Hehehe, no, no, no.
其他人：没没没
Others: No, no, no.
Jake:哈啊
Jake: Haha.
其他人：这个还没亏啊
Others: It's not a loss yet.
其他人：还没退这个我只是买了一点币
Others: Haven't withdrawn it yet, I just bought some coins.
其他人：还没付出去
Others: Haven't paid out yet.
Jake:所以还能再买是吧
Jake: So I can still buy more, right?
其他人：现在就是还能有结余
Others: Yeah, you still have some surplus.
其他人：就我刚只是在充纸币
Others: I was just topping up paper money.
Jake:哦哦还没买
Jake: Oh, oh, haven't bought yet.
Jake:是还没买
Jake: Haven't bought yet.
其他人：对哦还没买
Others: Yeah, haven't bought yet.
Jake:就可以有个低价购入
Jake: So we can buy at a lower price.
其他人：哎到货了
Others: Hey, it's here.
Katrina: 看看到货是啥样
Katrina: Let's see what we got.
其他人：然后赶紧给你买
Others: Then quickly buy it for you.
其他人：还能结余这么多笔
Others: Still have so much left.
其他人：我草要不要再他妈等一下
Others: Damn, should we wait a bit longer?
Katrina: ETH什么意思啊
Katrina: What's ETH mean?
Katrina: 就是货币单位
Katrina: It's a currency unit.
Jake:以太坊
Jake: Ethereum.
Jake:以太坊大概就是跟比特币绑定了
Jake: Ethereum is pretty much tied to Bitcoin.
Katrina: 感觉已经历史最低点
Katrina: Feels like it's at an all-time low.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：买上了
Others: Bought it.
Jake:买到了
Jake: Got it.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: We have money now.
其他人：钱没了
Others: Money's gone.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 扣你多少钱
Katrina: How much did it cost you?
其他人：这个单颗80刀吧
Others: This one is about 80 dollars each.
其他人：美刀新加坡的
Others: US dollars in Singapore.
Jake:新刀
Jake: Singapore dollars.
Jake:就按照按照您这边汇率的话就480
Jake: Based on your exchange rate, it's 480.
Shure: 我这边汇率
Shure: My exchange rate?
Jake:我就哈哈哈
Jake: I just... hahaha.
Jake:你汇率跟别人不一样哈哈
Jake: Your exchange rate is different from others' hahaha.
其他人：没有我买入的时候会会
Others: No, when I bought it...
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 我认识是这样
Katrina: That's what I know.
Katrina: 这皮蛋瘦肉粥还挺好喝
Katrina: This century egg and lean pork congee is quite good.
Katrina: 嗯这皮蛋瘦肉粥还挺好
Katrina: Yeah, this congee is pretty good.
其他人：哎你到了
Others: Hey, you're here.
其他人：你给哥你找出来
Others: Can you find it for me?
其他人：留一个短头发的女生带路吧
Katrina: 紫藤来了吗
Katrina: Is Violet here?
其他人：你俩对个暗号XXP
Others: You two should exchange a secret code, XXP.
Katrina: 哼哼
Katrina: Hmm hmm.
其他人：要不你打个视频
Others: How about you make a video call?
Shure: 快我要见见大国我想他了
Shure: Hurry, I want to see Daguo, I miss him.
Shure: 我想死你了
Shure: I miss you so much.
Shure: 我太想你了
Shure: I miss you a lot.
Shure: 能咋整啊
Shure: What can I do?
其他人：他找到了
Others: He found it.
Katrina: （歌词）beautiful and sweet
Katrina: (lyrics) beautiful and sweet
Katrina: 啊啊啊
Katrina: Ah ah ah.
Katrina: （歌词）偏偏痴心可以听我说
Katrina: (lyrics) A devoted heart can listen to me
Katrina: （歌词）啊啊啊啊
Katrina: (lyrics) Ah ah ah ah
Katrina: （歌词）天下已经感动
Katrina: (lyrics) The world is already moved
其他人：还手续费
Others: Plus the handling fee.
Katrina: 你知道这这孔怎么打开吗
Katrina: Do you know how to open this hole?
Jake:应该是有一个针
Jake: There should be a pin.
Katrina: 没明白他的构造
Katrina: I don't understand its structure.
Jake:它应该是有一个它
Jake: It should have a pin.
Jake:它就一个这个东西吗
Jake: Is it just this thing?
Katrina: 但是嗯
Katrina: But, hmm.
Katrina: 刚刚就把他下面这一环给撕了
Katrina: I just tore off the ring at the bottom.
Katrina: 但是好像没有送针啊
Katrina: But it seems there's no pin included.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
其他人：你感觉从这个呃
Others: Do you think from this, uh...
其他人：我们的成本上这逼每个都已经3块钱
Others: Considering our costs, each of these already costs 3 yuan.
Jake:有点贵
Jake: It's a bit expensive.
其他人：有点稍贵
Others: A bit pricey.
Jake:嗯你知道怎么开吗这东西
Jake: Hmm, do you know how to open this thing?
Katrina: 就是他这个孔怎么打开
Katrina: How do you open this hole?
其他人：直接刀
Others: Just use a knife.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Katrina: 其实我觉得说的有道理
Katrina: Actually, that makes sense.
Katrina: 直接剁就行
Katrina: Just chop it open.
Katrina: 这谁
Katrina: Who's this?
Jake:哦哦可以我拿了
Jake: Oh, okay. I'll take it.
Jake:我靠这红薯长成这样
Jake: Wow, this sweet potato looks like this?
Lucia: 嗯对他确实是烤红薯
Lucia: Yeah, it's definitely a roasted sweet potato.
Katrina: （歌词）开始感动
Katrina: (singing) Starting to feel touched.
其他人：最后一次
Others: Last time.
Katrina: 我需要充电宝
Katrina: I need a power bank.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:但是我们没什么充电宝
Jake: But we don't have any power banks.
其他人：这他妈得多少钱啊
Others: How much is this gonna cost?
Shure: 0.00000 他这个是
Shure: 0.00000, this is...
Shure: 他这个是市场决定
Shure: It's decided by the market.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 0.0005
Shure: 0.0005.
Jake:你要不找一个叉子
Jake: How about you find a fork?
Shure: 嗯这也不便宜
Shure: Hmm, that's not cheap either.
Jake:你要不找一个固定的插着
Jake: How about you find a fixed one to plug in?
Jake:你要是你活动
Jake: If you want to move it...
Katrina: 在外面
Katrina: Outside.
Jake:你在外面
Jake: You're outside.
Katrina: 现在应该也不着急充
Katrina: No need to charge it urgently now.
Jake:暂时还不着急
Jake: No rush for now.
Katrina: 那等会
Katrina: Then wait a bit.
Tasha: 剪刀在外面吗
Tasha: Are the scissors outside?
Katrina: 剪刀不在外面
Katrina: The scissors aren't outside.
Katrina: 好像在楼上
Katrina: I think they are upstairs.
Katrina: 好像楼上那个桌子上
Katrina: Probably on the table upstairs.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: （歌词）童年的童年记忆浮现在你
Katrina: (Lyrics) Childhood memories appear in you.
Katrina: 手机呢
Katrina: Where's the phone?
Katrina: 这是我
Katrina: This is mine.
Katrina: 这是你的手机还是我的手机
Katrina: Is this your phone or mine?
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: Neither.
Katrina: 我的哈哈
Katrina: It's mine, haha.
Alice:他们已经去取快递了吗
Alice: Have they gone to pick up the package?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 应该还没走吧
Lucia: I don't think they've left yet.
Katrina: 不知道
Katrina: No idea.
Katrina: 天天游荡着
Katrina: They just wander around all day.
Katrina: （歌词）没想到失去的勇气去
Katrina: (lyrics) Didn't expect to lose the courage
Katrina: （歌词）我还留着
Katrina: (lyrics) I still have it.
Jake:走走快递
Jake: Let's go, get the package.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Katrina: 快递要自己去取啊
Katrina: We have to pick up the package ourselves?
Jake:在外边外边
Jake: It's outside, outside.
Katrina: 天哪
Katrina: Oh my gosh.
其他人：雨轩
Others: Yuxuan
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Yes?
其他人：打火机还有吗
Others: Do you still have a lighter?
Katrina: 打火机在楼上
Katrina: The lighter is upstairs.
其他人：在你房间啊
Others: In your room?
Katrina: 在那个桌上
Katrina: On that table.
Katrina: 大厅的桌上
Katrina: On the table in the hall.
Jake:你那还有快递吗
Jake: Do you still have packages?
Katrina: 我的快递还没到
Katrina: My package hasn't arrived yet.
Jake:好你英文名
Jake: Okay, your English name...
Katrina: 还有一个小小的
Katrina: There's still a small one.
Jake:你有英文名吗
Jake: Do you have an English name?
Katrina: 我的英文名可以现场起
Katrina: I can make one up on the spot.
Katrina: 可以可以有
Katrina: Yes, yes I can have one.
Jake:嗯你哈哈哈
Jake: Hmm, you haha.
Katrina: 我给你是吗
Katrina: Should I give it to you?
Katrina: 发给你啊
Katrina: Send it to you?
Jake:那你你你自己
Jake: So you, you...
Jake:现场起还是
Jake: Will you make one up on the spot, or...
Katrina: 哦哦今天要
Katrina: Oh, do I need to today?
Katrina: 因为要用到吗还是怎么
Katrina: Because we need it, or what?
Jake:对要用一下
Jake: Yeah, we need to use it.
Katrina: 啊等一会起
Katrina: Ah, I'll make one up in a bit.
Jake:这么现场起
Jake: Make one up right now?
Jake:那就那就叫
Jake: Then just call...
Jake:那就叫勾吧
Jake: Let's call it Gou then.
Jake:要不哈哈哈哈
Jake: Or maybe hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈太难听了他要叫我沟
Katrina: Hahaha, that's too ugly! He wants to call me Gou.
Jake:英文名要给个英文名
Jake: You need an English name.
其他人： 你有英文名啊你
Others: You have an English name, right?
Jake:你怎么没有英文名呢
Jake: How come you don't have an English name?
Katrina: 我可以现起我可以下
Katrina: I can come up with one now.
Jake:想一想现起一个
Jake: Think of one right now.
Jake:现起一个j
Jake: Come up with one now.
Katrina: 等一下内蒙古给我打电话
Katrina: Wait, Inner Mongolia is calling me.
Jake:内蒙古 Jesus啊
Jake: Inner Mongolia? Jesus.
其他人：Jesus
Others: Jesus.
Katrina:  Jesus啊 完了
Katrina: Jesus, oh no.
Jake:好可以
Jake: Alright, that's fine.
Jake:这有点牛逼
Jake: That's kinda cool.
Katrina: 我可以讲
Katrina: I can say it.
Katrina: 就是有一个歌名叫什么克奇娜
Katrina: There's a song called "Kechina."
Katrina: 这就叫克奇娜
Katrina: Let's call it "Kechina."
Jake:古希腊
Jake: Ancient Greece.
Jake:古希腊古希腊
Jake: Ancient Greece, Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：古希腊掌管闹钟的神
Others: The god of clocks in Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 不是不是不是不是
Katrina: No, no, no.
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's good.
Jake:好古希腊
Jake: Alright, Ancient Greece.
Jake:走走拿快递
Jake: Let's go get the package.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Katrina: 他怎么不送快递了
Katrina: Why isn't he delivering the package?
Katrina: 等下我们自己拿
Katrina: We'll get it ourselves.
Jake:他太慢了
Jake: He's too slow.
其他人：我们俩去
Others: We'll go together.
Katrina: 够了我觉得
Katrina: That's enough, I think.
Jake:走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:够应该不够
Jake: It's probably not enough.
Jake:要不这样
Jake: How about this.
Jake:勾你来监工一下吧
Jake: Gou, you come supervise.
Jake:怎么样古希腊
Jake: How about it, Ancient Greece.
Jake:你来监工一下吧
Jake: You come supervise.
Katrina: 可以可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure, sure.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 监工什么
Tasha: Supervising what?
Jake:他们得得在进度上啊
Jake: They need to keep up with the schedule.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:现在还挺乱的
Jake: It's still pretty chaotic right now.
其他人：等我几分钟嗯
Others: Give me a few minutes, okay?
Katrina: （歌词）啊小黄花从出生那年就飘着
Katrina: (Lyrics) Ah, the little yellow flower has been floating since the year it was born.
Katrina: （歌词）啊童年的荡秋千
Katrina: (Lyrics) Ah, the childhood swings.
Katrina: （歌词）啊随记忆一直飘到现在
Katrina: (Lyrics) Ah, floating along with memories until now.
Katrina: （歌词）啊索索西拉西拉索西拉西拉索
Katrina: (Lyrics) Ah, so-so si-la-si-la so-si-la-si-la so.
Katrina: （歌词）啊下雨天我好想再淋一遍
Katrina: (Lyrics) Ah, on rainy days, I really want to get drenched again.
Katrina:  （歌词）啊没想到失去的勇气我还留着
Katrina: (Lyrics) Ah, didn't expect that I still have the courage I thought I lost.
Jake:再见古希腊
Jake: Goodbye, Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 哈哈好的
Katrina: Haha, okay.
Jake:走没找着
Jake: Go on, couldn't find it.
Katrina: （歌词）啊刮风这天我试过握着你手
Katrina: (Lyrics) Ah, on windy days, I tried holding your hand.
Katrina: （歌词）但偏偏雨渐渐大到我看你不见
Katrina: (Lyrics) But the rain gradually got so heavy that I couldn't see you.
Katrina: （歌词）还要多久我才能在你身边
Katrina: (Lyrics) How much longer until I can be by your side?
Katrina: （歌词）等到放晴的那天也许我会比较好一点
Katrina: (Lyrics) Maybe I'll feel better when the sun comes out.
Katrina: （歌词）从前从前有个人爱你很久
Katrina: (Lyrics) Once upon a time, there was someone who loved you for a long time.
Katrina: （歌词）但偏偏雨渐渐把距离吹得好远
Katrina: (Lyrics) But the rain gradually blew the distance so far.
Katrina: （歌词）好不容易又能再多爱一天
Katrina: (Lyrics) Finally, we could love each other for one more day.
Katrina: 但故事的最后你好像还是说了拜拜
Katrina: But at the end of the story, it seems like you still said goodbye.
Lucia: 咦雨轩你有看到那个剪刀吗
Lucia: Hey Yuxuan, have you seen the scissors?
Katrina: 没有所有人都在找剪刀
Katrina: No, everyone's looking for the scissors.
Katrina: 那个蓝色的吗
Katrina: The blue ones?
Katrina: 蓝色的可能在二楼
Katrina: The blue ones might be on the second floor.
Lucia: 有一个那个叫什么颜色
Lucia: There's one, what color is it?
Katrina: 红色吗
Katrina: Red?
Lucia: 有一个不知道从哪里出现的
Lucia: There's one that appeared out of nowhere.
Lucia: 剪刀是透明的
Lucia: The scissors are transparent.
Katrina: 啊那我没见过
Katrina: Ah, I haven't seen those.
Katrina: 啊又吹掉了
Katrina: Ah, it blew away again.
Alice:美丽的小姐
Alice: Beautiful lady.
Katrina: 天呐
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina: 做的跟坨屎一样
Katrina: It looks like a pile of crap.
Katrina: 真的会有人要吗
Katrina: Will anyone really want this?
Katrina: 你好你好
Katrina: Hello, hello.
Katrina: 哎怎么塞不进去啊
Katrina: Hey, why won't it fit in?
Katrina: 不知道推的什么歌
Katrina: I don't know what song is playing.
Shure: 这是我某一年的年度单曲
Shure: This was my song of the year one year.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Katrina: 当我飞奔向你
Katrina: When I ran towards you
Katrina: 不是那个青春剧吗
Katrina: Isn't that from a youth drama?
Shure: 没看过那剧
Shure: I haven't seen that show
Shure: 但是我知道
Shure: But I know
Shure: 这个star moon
Shure: This star moon
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Shure: 纹那个特别特别大的那个花呢
Shure: The one with that really big flower tattoo
Shure: 在哪在哪
Shure: Where, where is it?
Shure: 是这朵吗
Shure: Is it this one?
Katrina: 嗯只能把它单独着
Katrina: Yeah, you can only put it separately
Katrina: 我靠这怎么有一点点厚度就很难塞
Katrina: Damn, if it's even a little thick, it's hard to stuff in
Shure: 他怎么感觉没没抽干呢这个气
Shure: Why does it feel like the air isn't fully sucked out?
Katrina: 大的确实有点
Katrina: The big ones are indeed a bit
Katrina: 完全没干
Katrina: Totally not dry
Shure: 那怎么怎么抽呢
Shure: Then how do you suck it out?
Shure: 一般是拿嘴吸吗
Shure: Do you usually use your mouth to suck?
Katrina: 什么呀你说你说这个吗
Katrina: What? Are you talking about this?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah
Katrina: 我就用手的
Katrina: I just use my hands
Katrina: 这他他其实就是一层那个掀起来的
Katrina: It actually just has a layer that lifts up
Katrina: 盖上就感觉就很难了
Katrina: Covering it feels difficult
Shure: 我以为你这个口就是留着吸的
Shure: I thought that opening was for sucking
Shure: 然后里面这些小气泡是你的唾液
Shure: And those little bubbles inside were your saliva
Katrina: 哇这么恶心
Katrina: Wow, that's so gross
Katrina: 这个真太劣质了
Katrina: This is really too low-quality
Shure: （歌词）baby not a fool for you
Shure: (Lyrics) Baby, not a fool for you
Shure: （歌词）baby i'm a fool for you
Shure: (Lyrics) Baby, I'm a fool for you
Katrina: 塞进去
Katrina: Stuff it in
Katrina: 把你的吉他拿出来吧
Katrina: Take out your guitar
Katrina: 把你的吉他拿出来练练
Katrina: Take out your guitar and practice
Katrina: 困了
Katrina: I'm sleepy
Katrina: 天这真的有人要吗
Katrina: Wow, does anyone really want this?
Shure: 不复
Shure: No reply
Shure: 我们要复习
Shure: We need to review
Shure: 复习什么呢
Shure: Review what?
Shure: 哦晴天是吧
Shure: Oh, Sunny Day, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah